everett is one of my favorite typefaces  as a type designer i look at fonts  differently i look at how the letters  group together and how different letter  groups relate or not  basically seeing how well they were  crafted as a group  no one letter jumping out at me and to  that everett says [ __ ] that  everett pains me because every single  diagonal does not match anything else  look at everett bold in the word  television  there's a consistent rhythm from the top  and the bottom of the letters except b  and n  but it looks so cool i don't care  everett in all caps was built for  branding designed to be noisy and in  your face and as much as it should not  work it does and as much as i want to  hate it i love it for trying something  so fun  and that's why